each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
ok
so we're very pleased to have tanzeem
Chidori tonight pronounce your last name
ray chaudhuri chowdhury chowdhury here
from Dartmouth um she is at her soul and
media lab person though right and you
might even be able to guess from her
title who her thesis advisor it was but
sandy Pentland uh-huh so and and how I
should know your history I'm going to
ask you your history and repeat it
that's kind of stupid ok so I won't but
she's great and she's going to be
talking about inferring social networks
automatically from sensor data Thank You
Jennifer ok so I started a Dartmouth
about a year ago and previous to that i
was i was at intel and previous to that
at media lab so there's a kind of a
continuation of of my work and some new
stuff so out today i'll focus mostly on
my work on inferring social network but
i'll touch upon a little bit give you a
broader picture of what my general
research is about so Jerry I work on
using mobile sensors to interpret human
behavior you can see I started with this
big clunky device from my PhD thesis
this is what I transition to while i was
at Intel so devices are getting smaller
they're more sensors and more powerful
processors but what I'm interested in is
really kind of looking at how we can
learn our models of human behavior and
one of the reasons I prefer using mobile
devices are they're usually lightweight
they're continuously with the user as
opposed to sensors that are mounted in
the environment if the sensors go with
you so you can really have a 24-7 view
of what the user is doing and it also
has an advantage of being within the
users control so someone can turn it off
if they want to and that's often huge in
terms of privacy just having an off
button makes a big difference sometimes
and but we're kind of transitioning to
using mobile phones because the previous
device that
was out there had seven types of center
it had a microphone it had explore
accelerometer to detect movement it had
light temperature it could detect air
pressure a compass and if you think
about it an iphone or a lot of
smartphones have pretty much the same
set of sensors and what I work on is how
can you take this sensor data and look
at interpreting various types of
routines in a person's lives or their
activities the social networks that
belong to the places they go to and the
conversational structures and the
applications of understanding human
behavior and contexts are very broad and
probably familiar to most of you here
one is you can make computers smarter
that's that's definitely thin you have
location where assistance you can have
sisters that interact naturally with
individuals and you have systems that
respond in the context that manner the
application terrain that I'm
particularly interested in is in
improving quality of life our behaviors
I really provide a lot of clues about
our well-being or a physical health
emotional health cognitive health and
how can we and right now the measurement
of human behavior outside the doctor's
office is very very poor and how can we
use sensors to really improve and
provide a richer view of human behavior
to the individuals as well as their
caregivers or healthcare professionals
and
we'll have a lot of trouble trying to
define trying to define what a behavior
is you know about this whole controversy
and how are you know that's a good
question so I'm looking at usually right
now categorizing and actually looking at
physical behaviors of physical
activities that indicate physical
wellness so it's been kind of more
derived from that the help and so how
what would you know to determine when
someone is physically active weather it
could be whether you clean your house
through vacuuming or just take a walk
tickets there what kind of equipment you
might be using in the gym also looking
at social behavior and where my focus
mostly has been on looking at people's
how they interact who they interact with
and how it changes over time and the
other one has been doing mostly from the
eldercare domain in terms of what I
mentioned in activities of daily living
there they actually have a very well
defined category of 14 classes of
behavior they're considered to be
activities of daily living whether you
take care of your personal hiding your
food medication even things like finance
so definitely I have a very narrowly
defined view of what i mean by behavior
but also looking at where there has been
results tying those behavior to real
kind of measurements of quality of life
okay so and all that search so if you
look at it in terms of power behavior
patterns and what they reveal 11 aspects
of behavior I look at is conversations
and actually I primarily focus on not
looking at the words but just looking at
the stylistic content of conversation so
we can I subtracts for certain features
of ongoing conversation how how much the
person speaks how fast or slow the
person is speaking and just intonation
how to go back and forth turn-taking and
interruptions and all of these through a
lot of tedious manual coding have been
shown to result a lot of things a lot of
emotional and just
social States emotions people whether
kind of color like depressive state
things in its children with autism they
have social interaction style that are
different from normal individuals also
things like status in dominance so what
I'd like to be able to do is that can we
actually get to these behavioral
measurements automatically and also
relate to higher order information about
how they might impact our well-being and
in order to do that so they're
definitely a machine learning is a big
component and there's a lot of
challenges of how do you learn these
models from groups of people who are
really different and how do you evolve
that model and the it requires is
combining two i'm a believer that you
actually do need to have human in the
loop where the humans guide the learning
process because they do they are
intelligent and they know a lot more
they have a lot more context to guide
the system than a machine might have
from the beginning but you have to do
that in a way that doesn't drive people
crazy right so the usability is a big
aspect and and what I like to try to
combine in my research is is trying to
put these three things together how do
we learn models of human behavior but
engage the user in in a way that that is
acceptable to them so um today I will
mostly focus on as I mentioned the work
that we've done in looking at modeling
social networks and there is a lot of
work in modeling social network and my
my work has focused on really looking at
is the networks that happen in the
physical world through conversations so
and one of the one of the goals is to
say that we there's a lot of analysis of
links in the social network but how do
our behavior might impact the formation
of those legs that's what kind of what I
I would like to drive it and kind of the
work through the work I'm doing so given
that out this is kind of how I'd like to
proceed with the rest of my talk is i'll
talk about modeling group behavior give
a description of the type of data that
we collect how we model the network and
also talked about how our behavior
connecting behavior of ours how we
interact with others and how that might
be indicative of macro level behavior in
a social network but then i'll also kind
of briefly talk a little bit about some
of the work we're doing in in health and
wellness i structured the talk since
there is a lot more about social
networks at this large so most of the
focus is there but i can also kind of it
interest goal a lot more into the health
and wellness side because that's
something that my current research
involves a lot off so i started by
asking the question basically what i was
being a true media lab student i guess i
wanted to figure out what what what
makes people tick why are some people
more well connected than others or more
influential so social networks tell us
that some people are hubs but is that is
there something about in person's
behavior that might give us some q and
if you think about it that there is it
is just going beyond kind of looking at
presence and absence of link and this
actually a port from the tipping point
which i thought was quite appropriate
and there's some reference actually a
fit study that looking at how persuaders
have traits that go beyond what they say
they're these Norville group cues that
can tell characterize persuaders there's
also things about good people who are
very good at marketing and so I wanted
to unearth see if we can through sensors
and modeling of behavior try to
understand what are these cues and can
we actually quantify them and define
them in some ways
oh it's a it's a book by Malcolm
Gladwell about kind of looking at how
different social groups or certain
phenomenons can create like a tipping
point in a fad or how there's things
about fad what makes a message sticky or
how can what makes a good salesman
really sell a lot of product so so and
face-to-face conversations are important
channel and developing social network
and that's that's what the current
knowledge of face-to-face networks are
growing but it's still it's still sparse
there's lots of studies of social
networks in the way on the web email
networks Facebook networks but not that
much on on conversational networks but
conversations I studied but they're not
studied together so there in terms of
people looking at discourse analysis or
meeting in Leicester there's a lot of
work in analyzing conversations but
they're not linked to kind of model of
following a group around over an
extended period of time and the current
methods are very in some ways are a
hodgepodge of different techniques where
they they're in directing observations
through surveys and Diaries you get some
proxy information you often have direct
human observers who who actually observe
people in in action which can be a very
rich source of data but again that's
really hard to scale up so they're often
expensive and sometimes surveys are
biased and approximate so what we wanted
to do is actually really do a long
longitudinal study of looking at
interaction so what we did in in terms
of the scale of a network it's still
small but what we did we instrumented 24
individuals over the course of nine
months so these were actually first-year
graduate students who from the very
first week that became to campus were
instrumented so that we could actually
measure before this started before
they've already formed links and we
measured collected data one week every
month for the first academic year so
there's 90 data and we also collected
survey data alongside so looking at
their research interest in
collaborations and also a survey at the
end of the week with the mallet or who
they interacted with yeah there be a
bias here because only certain types of
people absolutely that's true that know
that that's that's definitely true and
what we tried to do is actually get as
much of the group as possible so they
were actually 26 incoming graduates to
that year and we managed to convince 24
so we actually really worked hard
because but they were also bribes they
gotta know this was at University of
Washington while i was at intel yeah
uh-huh so slightly less odd but still
computers didn't yes so our first year
CS graduate students and there were that
year there were 26 incoming students and
we got 24 yeah
oh absolutely I I don't think that in
terms of one of the things we did worry
about and which will come into play
later on is we're talking about things
like network centrality and we wanted to
say that we have the whole group right
so if we are saying making a statement
about that social group we actually it
was important for us to get as much of
the group so that's one of the reason we
add but I I totally agree that any of
the findings here are four
characteristics of that group and we
cannot Jenna I'm not going to make any
statement about generalizing to the
population at all yes so okay yeah they
were weak so this is how there is a kind
of incentive system work that it was
recorded it was the second of the kind
of two custom Hera wearable device that
you saw so slightly smaller it was like
three by two inches so they had to if
they were encouraged to wear it when
they were coming to work and and wear it
turn it off when they left there was a
varying amount of data different
subjects collected because you could
turn it off so on average we got I think
six and a half I had the number of per
day per subject so that's an average so
there is a high variance we divide
encouraged to keep it on all the time we
do not record and I I didn't go into the
detail but we don't record the raw audio
what I will actually talk about it so
I'll tell you a little bit about how we
collect the data and what was the other
question you can also just siphon just a
selection bias in your sample it's the
discretionary procedure
would have things that they want to talk
about the strangers and friends like
this thing we're recording everywhere
you're saying yeah sure it's not
recording every word we're saying we
actually as I mentioned we don't record
the words we actually just record the
air kind of stylistic nature and I'll
actually describe how we do that and the
other thing is that they definitely do
is advise that they can turn it off we
did do an informal survey in terms of
how much it affected their behavior they
were aware the first week that the worid
but after a time that the whole
department and they were so used to it
that they told us that they did not
notice it but it's still again it was an
informal survey it wasn't from the
entire group of people i think it was
about fifty percent of the individuals
so yes there is there is a selection
bias and one of the goals here is
actually how much can we measure about
the network and that's that's been one
of the driving factor I wouldn't say
this is a complete study off of a
network 24-7 but it's a how much can we
push with sensors and what level of
information we can get so it's actually
coming right now about how we how we
record that was the first question
you're going to record me twenty-four
seven and then I think we would not have
gotten a half of our subject for less
than half of her subject but one of the
things that I'm the field of ubiquitous
computing is about kind of computing
everywhere and and what is it often
times these devices and sensors are used
for recording but not for computing so
one of areas we wanted to push is that
why don't we actually use the
capabilities of these sensors that come
with processors and storage to actually
do more than that so what we did is what
we call like privacy said as added
processing of speed which is a very very
simple kind of in some way a trick or a
gimmick right so if you think about how
speech production work you have air flow
from the lungs and then your vocal child
so you have these voiced and unvoiced
source meter when you're uttering vowels
you have this periodic pitch which is
voice otherwise you have kind of almost
white noise your vocal tract filter
so which creates phonemes and words now
if we get rid of this shaping we lose
information about phonemes so well but
we still have this information about
human pitch and the rate of pit which
actually controls the rate of speaking
and and the various international
attributes of conversation so that's
that's exactly what we did that we
stored only information about the
paralinguistic content but through our
information that might help us recreate
speech so when we're recording it will
it never recorded audio it recorded
certain features that will help us
extract things like the the pitch
profile looking at speaking rate how
loud a person is speaking how they do
when you have multi priority
conversation how they are doing turn
taking what fraction of time did speak
so a lot of aspect of how someone
speaking but not what they're saying yes
um so any language that has kind of
these voiced the signal and actually
pitch right so things like if you have
like click languages and things it
wouldn't work but they were dominantly
so I tested it with we have the dominant
group who are Americans english-speaking
or Indians and Chinese and it does work
yeah
we could but we didn't yes yes we could
but we didn't explicitly because we
wanted it to be as comfortable we are
asking someone to record like 24 7 wear
a microphone so we actually there was
there is this kind of delicate balance
of how much can we collect and how much
will like just just actually make it so
unpleasant that will just kind of turn
off people yeah yes I lost my voice I
thought up because I was lowering the
pitch whenever I would lecture that
science Oh deliberately this is a common
problem early yeah they lower they'd
like to try to be more man-like yeah
okay no it does it does it overlap with
males pitch yes oh wow okay so I mean
they send me I want I got nodules and
scientists right and I'm you know about
tab as I Jennifer talks to head for the
border but yeah you can tell gender from
the information we collect yeah well we
did that and there was yesterday and we
said here's our code as well and but we
later on did actually with a colleague
of mine who does a lot of user studies
actually played by but if you try to
resynthesizer ohm from the information
we store how this is how it would sound
like and and actually looked at people's
feeling about privacy so choice would
you would you give us the data if we
recorded audio if we recorded this or do
you never want to any audio information
so it's it's still kind of
overwhelmingly people and there weren't
participants in this study
overwhelmingly prefer this over raw
audio but they're still like oh so you
can get emotion which we can you can get
gender & and there is still concerned
about even the level of information we
collect and not everybody in the general
population would be willing and these
our subjects also had monetary
compensation they got a smartphone they
got I think six hundred dollars to stuff
over the course of a year for a graduate
student that was enough okay so i'm i'm
not going to go into the details of that
but that's kind of one of the stepping
stones we have to kind of go through so
we did some work on saying how can you
identify multi-party conversations where
a subset of your individuals are Mike
and not Mike and we can do that and if
the quality varies based on what
fraction of your subjects are might so
if you have let's say eight individual
and two are mic'd are qualities in the
range of like fifty sixty percent if you
have five individuals where three is
Mike you can do much better so we do
that's one of our pre-processing step
exactly does that and I'm not going into
the detail can go over the specifics
later on but I won't be able to kind of
cover that and get to but this is kind
of actually some of the earlier work
based on the word that sumit Basu did
who is a Microsoft researcher and for
his PhD thesis but we build upon that in
terms of he actually looked at certain
robust features in terms of detecting
human voice and we utilized that and
build on top of that in order to but he
was looking at basically died a
conversation to person or over the phone
conversation where you actually only
have to but when what we did was
actually extend beyond that and looking
at multi-party conversation so I'm just
going to show you a result of how we
segment so basically if we have streams
of let's say we have three microphones
that we
no that are present and how we
characterize others in the conversation
is we say there's someone else speaking
or there is no one speaking so we
actually don't differentiate we possibly
could try to cluster that but we say we
don't differentiate from the unmarked
others so there might be five unlike
others or there might be two unlike
others we don't care and that's also
part of our human subjects agreement
because we are not allowed to try to
differentiate individuals that are not
we don't have informed consent from so
this is a ground fruit of a chunk of 65
seconds of data where its showing you
when in this case unfortunately I should
pick a better example where there's no
someone else but it's showing where no
one speaking a B or C is speaking and
this is the output of our probabilistic
model where higher intensity means more
probable so red is most likely when here
no one is speaking so you can see that
it a close losses higher probability and
blue is a lower probability so if you
can yeah so if you if you're trying to
do if you're trying to do if you're
trying to pick the model here you to
pick it with the highest probability in
this column right suit would be see the
highest probability corresponding to see
here there's some areas where it's more
model is more confident than others here
you can see that it's less confident
exactly that's that that is a good
question they do in this case you can
see that there is overlap in this
conversation but right now we don't we
are actually not explicitly modeling in
interruptions we just kind of switch
from A to B and we don't measure how
much a time that there is overlap that's
something that is also another
interesting aspect to look at
exactly exactly so we probably correctly
our model quietly currently our model
would probably just switch back and
forth right now it would switch but that
that is definitely interesting but we
haven't kind of looked at really
separating that to a great detail yep
but you're right it would switch so in
the end this is kind of what we would
get to this is showing you five days
it's the y-axis is showing the time in
the day so 11am to 8pm each bar is
showing you the conversations the width
is showing you the size of the group and
the colors have redundant they also
correspond to the size of the group so
you can kind of get a week-long pictures
of what's happening of all the
conversations that going on among those
24 individuals and you can see that this
was actually u-dub had a friday
afternoon tgif for a tea so there's lots
of small conversations going on and
actually tuesdays and thursdays or when
the colloquium happens so also you can
see a lot more and you see that these
were first year graduate students who
had this one of their core courses
Tuesday and Thursday morning so you can
get a flavor of the conversations that
go on but also looking at within a
conversation how the dynamics is
occurring so here it's showing you the
blue is the other and 2 this is 3 and 16
that how this is showing the probability
so basically when two and three and 16
are talking and there's someone else
present in the conversation you can also
but at the same time you can look at
individual separately so each plug here
is an individual and each line is
showing you a pair and the length to
show you how long they interact the
showing you whether they interact
one-on-one or in groups so the shallow
the shallow animals means they interact
in one-on-one and small groups and
larger angles into it that they interact
in large groups so whether they actually
spend any time one-on-one or only they
spend time when they're in larger groups
so you can see that these are the
different individuals in our study and
you can see very different
characteristics in that there's some
people who are extremely social and
there's some people who are not and even
in terms of the types of conversations
they can have so there's a wide range of
conversational patterns that we even saw
yes still the length is the amount of
time so some people only have short
conversations and others have long
extended conversations yes this is the
time i averaged over the entire period
so but the data that I've showed you so
far is is not really measuring kind of
social ties it's showing you so a local
this behavior how much who talks to who
and one of the things that we'd like to
do is kind of tie that in to really
build a network model or a probabilistic
model about about the ties and that's
that's that's where we were going that
from from conversations we want to go to
go to networks we haven't yet but it yes
what does
so true sorry this is true sensors right
there is not like currently sensors and
it's measuring conversations or whether
you're talking to each other it cannot
say like the notion of a friend is is
lot richer than that so we're saying
that you don't know whether someone or
even like if you could have a
conversation with someone for five
minutes are they your friend or you have
to have multiple conversations or do you
have to have lots of friends in common
to be friends right
friendship and support yes no pick it up
and so we are not to realize so are you
saying what we are saying that the
actual friendship structure is hidden
and we want to take our observation and
maybe some characteristics of just
networks to actually build infer a graph
that is the most likely network
structure that our data supports so the
network structure we are assuming is
hidden we want to infer a latent
structure from our observations
information now absolutely may be there
but not observable so one thing is to
say is the measurement of it and shows
that the regulations in business and I
don't see a correlation but all this is
some more there is another one which you
can prove it according to the French
what's she saying is that you can
actually for meeting even for behavioral
data for example I spent a lot
I'm saying Fred say that you actually
have to be the drone even get it yep
even modeling Browns perceptions of pies
has been a big struggle fantasy ology so
one of this is a matter what your ignore
you are in forming a structure but
automatical just go from that structure
to this even if you have some measures
that might be more likely for sure don't
make such a case or what can he he could
be the next feel better we observe is
not really synaptically
well we can't observe a friendship
directly with with this and that's what
she's trying to do it she's trying she's
got this this behavioral structure there
she'll try to infer a friendship
structure and then I assume you ask
people or something exactly then we try
to correlate it with the survey data but
it's still it's it's still the case that
from the behavioral data and the level
of analysis we are doing it's really
hard to say that this person is an
acquaintance who I spend a lot of time
with versus this person is a really good
friend of mine who I spent five minutes
friendships are sort of mighty sexy
characterized by local geographic
interaction
that would be a problem if what what
Bernie was saying before wasn't it right
like if you were tight use generalized
with overall population than fantasy
and that was by design we actually did
do it all by design and possibly and
this is actually kind of because most of
the time people get really upset by
saying that if we do observe friendship
so it's a it's a negative reaction which
is great if she said I can observe
French if I'd be happy now but most of
the most of the time the notion is that
we are not reading people's mind and we
don't know intention it's these are
observation and they can have many
different interpretation and that's kind
of basically what this is alluding to
that it could be interpreted many ways
and I'm not going to make a claim that
this is purely friendship okay so um so
what we're trying to get it is that we
have conversations right and we don't
just have we just have kind of patterns
of conversations by colors not showing
up very well and from that we have a
whole group of people who are
interacting and what we want to do is in
firms in further network structures so
in this case what we tried to say that
we have the observation and your we want
to say what's the most likely network
structure that supports these
observations and these are links and
they could be friendship there could be
just they're just links in our in our
kind of interpretation yeah what is the
motivation of doing that yes I'm so one
of the things is i want to say as i said
from the very beginning i'm going to
come back and related to behavior how
does our behavior guide the links that
we form and actually low level how we
speak and how we speak with others how
we cause others to change their behavior
when they stick to a to me or anyone in
the network is it it is there any
connection with the structural
properties that's that was it because
that is that is not very well understood
in terms of for example can I know that
given the way if there was a sense of
measuring me that how I would fit into
an organization or
am I am I the leader type or who are the
others will lead a type and how am i
different are their behavioral
characteristics that are different they
are characteristic off well that's a
good question we have explored more
deeply characteristics of individuals we
haven't looked too deeply looking at
kind of relationships partly because
also that requires a lot more
observations of a certain relationship
type where we have lots of conversations
but prepare like conversations a lot
more limited okay all right so I'm going
to try to speed up a little bit um so
what we okay all right so what we did
and this is kind of this is a very
common model that's used in kind of
looking at social networks is
exponential kind of random graph model
where you're trying to infer a graph
from certain observations and you're
waiting those observations and those
observations are often kind of in social
that we trying to be designed to be
socially intuitive and what I mean by
social intuitive very very common
features that are used in exponential
random graph is density and triangles so
basically human social networks aren't
very dense they're not fully connected
so you have usually when you're looking
at it you have a negative weight for
density because you have you have
certain density and then you not get
connected to everyone in the network
especially for large that way and the
transitivity is just friends of friends
yeah you are do you have a quick oh no
you're skeptical no I
it's an interesting way of making it
sparse by putting it away actually that
is learned so typically typically pseudo
you're learning the weights and you're
defining the features and from a lot of
the kind of server based models of
networks that the density tends to be
negative way because you do to see
sparsity in actual networks and the
transitivity is that you tend to connect
to have lots of friends of friends or
friends yes absolutely right now no
we're not doing that and we are actually
this is kind of a standard network model
and we're not actually doing exactly
that and actually people do use much
more nuanced notion of kind of
transitivity and and I say that they'll
see how many how many shared friends do
you have right not like do you have two
shared friends three shared friends and
friends right so it's and in some
ways if you have lots of share friends
your friendship might be stronger than
if you just have one shared friend but
one of the things in terms of modeling
it is if you have a large network and
you're trying to model this transitivity
number of shared friends and if you have
a feature for one she had friend to
shared friend and you're trying to learn
await you have lots of parameters to
learn and you could potentially put some
constraints in in this overall kind of
shape of how many shared friends you
have right that wants you you the
probability of you forming a link when
you have lots of share friends might
become higher as the number of Sharon
increase but they might be in some kind
of diminishing return so you might want
to put a non linear constraint and
that's something to make your model more
sparse so what and that's that's also
kind of existing
if that has been done by Mark Hancock at
University of Washington actually we're
looking at putting a nonlinear function
that map's these these parameters to a
lower dimensional space so that you can
do something like a diminishing return
so there are so again you want to you
basically kind of parametrize it with
this certain multiplicative rate and and
also another geometric rate parameter
and you're learning those parameters so
you can actually learn the shapes as
well um and what we are trying to do is
an extension beyond that is that we
don't actually have the networks we're
not measuring up the network statistics
we're measuring conversations and we
want to actually infer the network
structure from our observed variables
and so we basically have a hidden model
we're now also we have two different
features which we character is one is
the structural features that are very
common in network in terms of the
density and transitivity but we also
have observation feature of how much
time do you spend in conversation and
what's your kind of behavioral profile
are you a very talkative person right
what's your kind of general chattiness
in terms of feature and also how much
time do you spend in conversation and
looking at tying those features as well
as that the structural features so we're
looking at one of the observation
features it would be time spent in
conversation how how many milites spend
in conversation again you can kind of
build it into certain kind of histograms
of how much you spend time and
conversation and again you can constrain
it that if you spend an hour after that
it doesn't really matter if you spend
five hours there is a diminishing return
in terms of the strength of a link okay
so basically as Jennifer you were
mentioning so we do have the weight of
an e each histogram is kind of defined
this way I will actually go through this
so you have one kind of rate parameters
so you have a rate per
data are and also multi qulity weight
which you're trying to learn from your
data and also you can just have a linear
cost for example one could say there is
a cost of spending time in a
conversation and given your observation
what you're trying to do is learn these
weights and given the weights that you
can learn you can actually learn
different shapes so you're not actually
specifying because that would be that
would require a lot more knowledge than
we do have so you're trying to actually
basically learn and one of the with what
we learned end up in is that if you
think about the probability of you spend
the minute spending conversation given
you have a social time you don't this is
this is basically what we learn from our
data automatically in our data set this
is kind of the shape of the most
socially significant time in
conversation so you can kind of see and
this is a characteristics of our data
right we don't have a lot of data for
lots and lots of long conversations so
then it kind of peaks and then kind of
goes down right so the probability that
if you have a social tie that the more
kind of peak is at around 20 minutes and
and then obviously the amount of time if
you don't have a social tie you might
have a few sporadic oh yeah or in this
case basically it's saying whether there
is a you infer a link or not just a
connection between
in terms of so what is there's some
other measure of social time besides the
length of conversation yeah so there is
so you're trying to learn you're trying
to infer the probability kind of off a
tie existing given conversation as well
as so as the structural features of the
density and the transitivity so all of
those you're defining the joint
probability as well as the chattiness of
the person in general right so you have
certain behavioral features of the
individual and certain properties of the
network structure okay yes so how much
is there a fixed amount that
oh is that great proportionate to the
language conversations such that you
know if we're talking for 50 minutes we
have it five minute break the day we
were talking it feels like very small
breaking conversation yeah and we see
that in our data so what we do is our
inference about conversation we make a
decision every 20 seconds so you can
actually see a gap if there's a 20
second gap you would see a gap but we
actually do some smoothing on top of
that but anything above a minute if you
have a gap it actually segments it into
a separate conversation so you're
absolutely right that phenomenon is in
effect here and you can deal with it
bite it's really really hard to define a
conversation which we kind of like when
two people in the conversation a third
person joins in is this the same
conversation or do you say little bit
it's a different conversation if you go
back if your officemates you start
talking about something then go back and
check your email and start talking about
different things should it be same or
different conversation I we don't have
the answer and we just made a kind of
heuristic way that we're not going to
try to make that decision and we're just
going to make a uniform decision every
time that if there is a break of more
than one minute it's a separate
conversation because we just we don't
have the knowledge to make that decision
yes
yeah yeah yep okay so from now also
given that we can actually infer so
we're looking at a distribution over
over the graph and we can also find
what's the most likely graph and from
that we can also look at things like
centrality measures of centrality and
that's another thing that we actually
look at is in photograph and looking
looking at Central and specifically we
looked at closeness centrality because
there it's more robust than betweenness
centrality in terms of outliers and
there's some sociological work that
shows that these are indicative of
leadership traits and there's some work
I think from the 1970s that look at that
people who are have high between this or
clothes and sensuality czar perceived as
leader so we kind of chose that mostly
being influenced by by that and one of
the things that we looked at is so from
that we can actually build so this
network structure is is showing these
twenty four individuals mapped in in a
circle where more essential person is in
this in the middle and then they go
radially go up and I'll actually come
back to that but basically this is
showing you what's the most what the
network graph that we inferred that was
most likely in terms of and I will come
back to the size so right now I haven't
explained what the sizes and I'll and
you can see the links which are in light
light gray but in terms of what we and a
lot of the discussions that came out is
what we measure is how do we know that
we've measured the right Network and the
closest thing we can do is look at
surveys right because we're not we're
not collecting ground through 24 7 and
we ask them collaboration so at the end
of the week that we ask the
collaboration about research and
coursework and also actually this we
also had a thing of where the people
have you interacted with this person
face-to-face to socially and also we
have some data which we haven't used
about do interact with them over email
and IM but this is this is not absolute
ground food so we are expecting some
agreement but it's it's a noisy it's
kind of a noisy observation of the same
network that's kind of what we are we
get so if we look at look at the
inferred network with the survey data we
get about seventy seventy-five percent
agreement right and if we looked at just
kind of a random Network which have the
same density of our learn network so we
are actually helping the random Network
in a way that look from from based on
our conversation data actually giving it
the same density we get about sixty four
percent agreement so being able to add
some of the kind of combining the
structural and behavioral information
gives us better agreement but it doesn't
go beyond if we just did a simple
threshold that much field it's like 71
versus 75 it's about four percent and
the simple conversation basically we put
a simple threshold say if you spend more
than one minute in conversation there is
a link I think it was about five minutes
in conversation so but one of the
reasons we're interested even though the
simple even if the results are close one
of the reasons that we are interested in
kind of looking at modeling it the way
we do is to have parameters that in some
ways that interpreter will write the one
that I looked at like the social time
time spent in conversation to actually
have parameters in ways that might in
some way by useful to sociologists or to
be able to interpret what's going on in
the network whereas a simple threshold
doesn't get us there another thing that
we also looked at is tying it back to
the micro level behavioral properties so
right now we're looking at in
the link based on just conversations but
given a conversation we capture things
like speaking rate and pitch and how
they go back and forth and what we can
then do is a measure how people change
when they come and talk to a given
individual so in this case let's say why
is an individual he or she has multiple
conversations and for each
characteristics let's say turn-taking
pattern or pitch what we do is how much
does X change from their average
behavior when they come and talk to you
why and and then we do an average of
that so how much do all the people who
come talk change the behavior when they
come and talk to y and surprisingly one
of the is it is that people who were
more central cause cause others to have
more not cause it's related we see a
correlation of higher behavioural change
so in terms of very very low level
behavior in terms of how they change the
pit their rate of and and the
turn-taking length that there is
actually a correlation between how they
change and their network position in
terms of their centrality
so we're looking at average change oh if
the individual only talks to one person
um yeah in that case we don't know we
actually did do a check for it that
there is there is no one in our network
that only talks to one person but yes oh
no but she's talking about the other way
I think she said if you are central
other people from their average one
minute yeah yeah yeah yeah so and this
is basically what the size and the
colors were showing so it's showing how
much to others chair what's the incoming
change so the the bigger and the redder
the person is that the more incoming
change so the others change their
behavior more so you can see the most
central person is not the person with
the greatest change but slightly off but
there's there is a correlation so it's
not a perfect much but it is a
significant like statistically
significant correlation in terms of and
you can see people who are in the
periphery I don't cause that much how
very little incoming I'm change yeah so
we actually did that and that's
something we are going to do in this
work but in a previous study we actually
looked at on that and this was part of
mine kind of thesis work actually what
we did was um did the same thing in
terms of modeling network but what we
looked at is if you look at the
conversation how much do you need to
wait mm the individual models to fit
that conversational profile just in
terms of turn-taking so there you are
actually are looking at how much people
change their own behavior or maintain
their own or let's start adapting to the
other person's behavior and in this case
we actually did see that more central
fear that the central people are more
stable so they don't change their
behavior as much and and that was just
looking at turn-taking so one of the
things we're also kind of well we're
happy that we have two data sets that
one collected at MIT and one collected
University of Washington that shows
these behaviors features do matter but
we're also trying to kind of make
comparisons between the two as well know
so I mean I find it a little too
president I would might have thought
that like somebody who doesn't talk that
much like an Asperger's type person
which it'd be kind of Ali not very
central to the network and yet would
always talk in the same way yeah I just
that's what I expected to yeah um that's
an interesting observation we don't know
kind of at the if you're thinking about
that Asperger profile right how where
they fall we don't do any screening of
with that so it's a good observation in
terms of how can we do a finer kind of
categorization of our subjects right now
we just treat them all all the same and
and maybe they're there could be yeah it
possibly could be but
that's true that's true that's true um
yeah yeah that's an interesting thing to
actually really look at kind of a lot
more of the variability in in the
conversational style or even try to do
one of the things we want to do is kind
of group those conversations and maybe
some individuals do have more
variability than others something we
haven't done yet but we actually do want
to kind of go beyond just looking at the
links to actually have links that are
characterized by conversation types not
just just presence and absence yeah
who are interacting with each other
mm-hmm how do you compare the two
central individuals well um in it we
have all the data we haven't kind of
looked at the actually comparing we
don't have that many central people
delft data but you can actually go and
further break it down in terms of the
types of conversations they have to try
to see if there is different types of
central people we have not done that but
there's a lot of lot of kind of data we
already have in terms of how long they
speak what type of what place is this
peepli I actually haven't even looked at
the location of conversations at all we
actually have that where what what is
the type of place they interact in so
possibly there is that you could look in
yes yes yeah yeah yeah so in in this
case our all we are so far saying is
that the more central you are the more
you change others change right so if
you're comparing to central person do
you are you the one who is doing are
others changing their behavior more than
you or not right so that's the simplest
things
yes but when you're looking at that
you're actually looking at how the
average of all the other peoples who are
talking to you right so if so you have
you saying that do more people change
their behavior when they talk to you
versus other that's that's the simplest
thing you can do from the analysis that
we have or maybe that over the number of
conversations well we don't really know
how the distribution of the variance
here and the second is dyad pairs and
plotting diet pairs over you know it's
big the diet pair rather than
analysis and applauding their difference
in sensuality over their difference from
their average speed new style so that
diet pairs are very asymmetrical is
there going to be a lot of change diet
pairs that are very symmetric is there
going to be a lot of change so just
getting yeah that's a good pun yeah
that's a good so these sorts of thoughts
give you a distribution is this because
otherwise I think what we're doing is
yeah yeah yeah yep yeah that's that's a
good observation and we do actually have
the variances and not a nice what kind
of thing but yeah it's an excellent
suggestion okay so I'm going to mount
aggressive bit in terms of talking a
little bit about some of the other stuff
that I've been working on so what next
in terms of in terms of the challenges
of learning from cents a day that one of
the things that we are working on is
really how to engage the user and help
the learning system evolve over time
right so we right now we're building
models of conversations but as I
mentioned before I'm looking also at
activities and places and these aspects
of behavior and not here to people
people are very different right to
people most people are like they might
have commonalities but they have their
own kind of flavor and and eventually
our goal is that your cell phone will
know a lot about you and you have a
models of your behavior and can help you
it achieve your goals or error but in it
to get there together exactly cell phone
is your life coach and but it needs to
it needs to come with certain
understanding of human behavior but it
needs to learn from its user and evolve
over time and it needs to do that
without driving the user kind of crazy
so what we're actually looking at is
right now it's very very tedious to
train this model a lot of these models
are supervised you collect some data
label it or graduate students label it
and then and and then you learn and then
you give it to your grandma and it
breaks because you walk differently from
an aging elderly person but it might be
enough to bootstrap so that it knows
maybe you're possibly walking and and
try to combine combine the information
and maybe prompt to you when it's most
useful when it's most uncertain or when
it thinks something new is happening and
the other benefit with with mobile
phones and devices as millions of people
are using it and if millions of people
gather sensor data and we can profile
them in terms of types we can actually
also benefit in terms of learning based
on groupings of individuals can we build
a phone that shares data from active
people who go hiking and and have a
better model of all the different
activities they're doing versus someone
maybe who is spends most of the time
like going to museums and cultural
events right so there are different
flavors of people and can we actually
group them and learn from them over time
and and share information between them
to help our algorithm so that's kind of
something that and actually look at
really I haven't talked much about the
activity stuff in terms of Phil I also
look at looking at just simple physical
activity do you take the stairs or do
you take the elevators or do you go for
bike what kind of you do you cook at
home and how much time do you spend in
meetings and things and really trying to
do some experiments in terms of
understanding what profiles behavioral
profiles can help in terms of different
quality of life metrics
so we've done um so I will actually
serious yes how many different kinds of
behavior and yes so how many we don't
know yet right we're still on but we did
we did actually do things I the
combination of sound and movement we've
looked at doing cooking watching TV
vacuuming like doing laundry so we have
actually kind of looked at seeing if we
can do certain classes like today again
guided by these activities of daily
living but yes then what if you do
something new it's always the case we
did this kind of physical fitness
experiment where we had things about
different machines in the gym we had
information about taking stairs biking
but then it got 11 someone said that I I
do a lot of vacuum i vacuumed my house
every day and I should get credit for
that or and the other one was was yeah
there's and a lot of people complain
about the pedometer not giving credit
for taking stairs which is if you take
the scene you are actually doing more
intense activity so but the other was
dancing I I go out dancing and your
system doesn't detect and those are the
cases I think you do need to notice when
something new is happening and
potentially incorporate that but you can
do a wide rate to we looking at
combining location so if you can say
this is this is the city center where
there is shops and restaurants and cafes
and bookstores that can constrain the
the possible options and then you're
moving exactly or you wouldn't be
walking around in a restaurant but you
will be at a shop and then looking at
the sound you will probably have a lot
more kind of conversations at a
restaurant a bookstore will be quieter
so combination of those sensing can help
you differentiate the different
different types of behavior so what we
are actually about to do in like a
week so a Dartmouth there is a medical
school affiliated with the medical
school there's an elder care facility
called Kendall which is populated by
mostly retired Dartmouth professors and
others who are really interested in
volunteering for experiments so we're
actually doing an experiment with with
actually a doctor at Dartmouth where we
are looking at model in measuring their
physical activity and social isolation
so social isolation is a big problem in
elderly people if you if your spouse
dies and you're become isolated you
become depressed and then it actually
triggers cognitive decline similarly for
physical activities and what we are
going to do is measure their behavior
for a period of two weeks and the a
combination of couples and people who
are widowed or single as well do
standard surveys so there are these
physical activity surveys there's
depression scale surveys to actually
measure how to try to understand can we
actually have predictors from behavior
that correlate well with surveys and and
basically I think that it can have
impact both at an individual level that
you raise awareness just the fact that
someone a lot of people say that they
don't even know how much they walk right
the pedometer is one step towards that
but also looking at kind of family and
caregiver a lot of elderly their family
members take care of them and there is a
huge burden in terms of a lot of people
actually quit their jobs to take care of
aging parents so if you could have a
monitoring and automated alert system
but also the doctor I work with also
does a lot of Public Health and they say
that it's really try to understand and
measure like help outside the doctor's
office and how different factors affect
the well-being is very poorly understood
and even just just how much physical
activity someone does is the death of
the person have a lot of social
connection is is really hard to get and
really affects a person's health and
that's some of the things that we're
we're looking at so and the kind of goal
is that we should be them would be
able to kind of increase access to care
over time improve the quality of
actually make it much more cost
effective so that's that's a kind of
digression of the Ted of work I do and
and that's that's it and obviously I
have the my main graduate students I
that have done it when Danni Wyatt is
the one at the University of Washington
who is doing a lot of work on the social
network stuff and and like collaborators
who have been involved in the various
aspect in terms of the medical sighs and
also the device
given this is there a case
I think one of the more I think being
able to use a cell phone is a big
advantage in terms of getting people's
buyin people already carry a cell phone
that people hate carrying extra stuff
which we have the problem especially
with elderly people like you can give
fair student to carry it but if we
wanted to kind of say carry this for a
year to someone who is not being kind of
paid to participate in the study it's
it's cumbersome so I think the fact that
phones are in a state that you can
actually do a lot of the the sensing is
is great but I think the challenge is on
the processing how do you take these raw
sensor traces and and and get higher
level information that's useful by
individual and and in some ways
predictive i think is is the challenge
but I'm biased that's what I work on so
yep oh yeah continuously I'm going to
actually play sorry while you're asking
question this is kind of an application
that we're envisioning in terms of poops
okay sorry so that you can see a little
bit of what we have in mind so this is
will show you the types of thing you
could do on on a phone in terms of
individual behavior and categorization
so I'll let it play while i answer you I
mean my networks form would be master
frequent they have
but so have you look at applications
where you actually look at people mean
maybe of grad students would actually
work if you would have have a bigger
population people initially kind of make
these random connections to people until
finally crystallizer sort of a certain
certain type of network because that
would technology yes yeah absolutely so
I what we're currently working on is a
temporal kind of evolution of the
network model to look at the kind of the
temporal dynamics but but you're
absolutely right so in in the beginning
one of the things that how do you take
even noisy audio measurement and group
people into conversations reliably
they're not close talking microphones
that microphones that are kind of
clipped onto their kind of pocket or
shoulder stuff so there is a lot of kind
of initial challenges in terms of are
these models going to be good enough
that we were challenged but you're
absolutely right that what we want to do
is scale scale up and look at kind of
the evolution and temporal trends and
with the activities we are doing a lot
of that we're looking actually at
routines and and behavior temporal
models with the social network we're
just about kind of starting to do a like
looking at the evolution in terms of
time so exactly what you're saying we're
trying to look at these and even just
the probability of you forming a link
could be high at the beginning and then
it kind of tapers off right so can we
actually look at how the model evolves
over time which is not homogeneous which
is often time a lot of probabilistic or
assume a Markov process but can we
actually learn the pattern
I mean for example I mean who says Allah
top model to study on email networks and
found that you know because students are
randomly assigned and so you could look
at the effect of geography on how power
african-americans on the power to know
african-americans and looking at the
effects of discrimination so I was
wondering if this is also something
you're good they apply this to because
will be interesting to see like you know
whether people from different say groups
are you know avoiding each other
initially when they meet or it is
something that there's some or worse and
keeping up relationships I mean these
are all kind of things you could do by
absolutely and one of the things we're
trying to look at in the elder care
study is that people who are in certain
groups or activity groups do they tend
to be more physically or mentally alert
and I their trends and do we if they
participate in a group but they're
actually doing the activities as well
through measurements and that's exactly
what we're looking at in the kind of
eldercare study the what okay so the
algorithm for the graph was used mostly
using mcmc so we're using kind of Markov
chain Monte Carlo but we're looking at
cashing some samples to make it
efficient it is really really slow
otherwise and we also have to do the
exponential random graph in terms of the
parameters they have certain
degeneracies so we are actually putting
some prize on the model so that to avoid
such things but in terms of the actual
learning process is primarily variations
and tweaking of mcmc yeah yeah maximum
likelihood estimate yeah using MC MC
well that's that's an excellent
excellent point I think so it there is a
whole area of work which I don't work on
in terms of persuasive technology right
so how do you actually how do you
actually take this information and
present persuasive so how do you
actually so for example one of the
things my colleague did again so she
built a fitness kind of a device of
fitness phone in terms of how it would
give you feedback and what she did was
instead just made it a background screen
which is a flower garden on your phone
all it did was populate the flower
garden based on your activity so you
didn't have any social stigma that your
friends would do saw your phone would
know because you are the only one who
knows what this everyone to everyone
else it's a flower garden a background
screen right and and then you could
choose to share it but actually see what
she did is measured that there is a
difference in terms of activity level
from people who actually got some
feedback in this way versus a control
group so and and there were actually
people then she screamed for people who
are overweight and wanted like already
had a weight problem and it was
interested in losing weight so I agree
it's it's an it is a challenging issue
of how do you convey the information
often time if someone have a problem
they're much more much more motivated
but some people are just interested in
getting the information as well so when
we a lot of our subjects suit like they
wanted to just see the data and maybe
that might be a way of nudging them into
good behavior
did I hopefully like it shows we being
super active or something and this is
actually showing that you could actually
have a real-time map you know this was
for our doctors in terms of this is
showing people who are similar to you so
the intensity is mapping people's
behavior who is similar to you so if you
wanted to do some kind of community
based assessment you can actually look
at people who are behaviorally similar
yes that's true um so I think there's a
lot of things in the end we are giving
it to people who want to use it in the
way they want to use it and eventually
if you want to share some data you have
to explicitly authorize sharing that
data right so what we what we want to do
is show the benefits make it possible
and give you control but definitely
there's many ways it could be abused and
and something I think will be addressed
as a combination of giving people
control having having proper policies in
place also in terms of using the data
for example in health care there is no
guidelines of how you can use the data
right and and a lot of these things
these devices aren't at FDA approved and
actually like I saw one nurse who uses
accelerometer to for copd fda approve
accelerometer only called a cost 450
dollars which is crazy and they give you
a sample once per second which is a
really crappy accelerator for 450 bucks
but it takes enormous cost of making
something FDA approved so also there is
a lot of kind of eye thing applications
in the consumer and and also kind of
family caregiving network as well
no the device that I was talking about
was a stand stand alone / standalone
device that was just accelerometer is
trying to detect movement so it it's
it's used to actually trying to they're
trying to characterize gates and
apparently a severe attack in terms of
copd can be predicted by certain change
in gate patterns oh oh sorry I I
thought it was thank you I combine
things actually a lot of is actually
kind of figuring out automatically with
sensors to to use I work with audio gps
accelerometer as well as certain
environmental cues in terms of light so
for example you know the sensors that
help best differentiate between walking
and taking stairs is a combination of
accelerometer and barometric pressure
because you see elevation change and and
there's whether someone is standing or
taking an elevator so we actually
because one of the approaches we were
trying to is that you have this basket
of sensors from which you can extract
features can you automatically pick up
which ones are relevant and that was
very interesting in terms of n which was
great because pedometer people who wear
a pedometer always complains that all
four six flights of stairs and I got
like the same number of step counts so
they're like completely like over the
move and it could detect like taking the
stairs
right now no because we're not at that
kind of we are mostly kind of in that
designing the algorithms and this is
this is kind of more as a demo platform
right so it were there is nothing
technically in the way that wouldn't let
you do that but currently it's it's not
there
an entire afternoon speak to communicate
by my wife died when I was small we've
of b movies was a sign of prosperity the
what what sign know from what was it
please Oh being a beast yeah that means
to feed yourself and you were doing
manual labor to the convertibles cover
nowadays is a socially correlated with
different economic stuff and so it is
stealing as most fun we can swing so the
question really is can you I'm sure you
can write to my kind of my goal is to
have the technology at the stage that
you can do that you can actually have
system and and they will be able to
detect a lot of you at the interesting
trends in a person's life and be able to
kind of adapt over time so that it
doesn't just if something changes it
completely breaks down and say I have
never seen this before and like can't
can kind of evolved so that's that's
kind of what my work has been focused on
is really being able to do very very
rich behaviors longitudinally
continuously so that you can do a lot of
a lot of such studies I would say right
now there isn't that sense because can
the technology is just kind of evolving